jana kramer breaks down while discussing
her past the country star says she was
almost murdered by her first husband my
grandpa has always been my angel and I
remember praying to him saying I don't
even want to be here anymore because I
don't know how to get out of the
situation when we were struggling he was
choking me I didn't see everything I see
my mom I see my funeral like I literally
have like that flash of like my whole
life Jana was only 19 at the time her ex
was convicted for premeditated attempted
murder
then later committed suicide that GMA
interview came after Jana delivered an
emotional performance on Dancing with
the Stars Monday night
who knew though Jana that you were such
a survivor I mean you've been through
some things girl you've come out the
other side yeah and I think that's it's
it's been tough because everyone always
judges a book by its cover and you never
know someone's inner struggle you never
know what people have been through and
I'm happy now that people are finally
get some you know to know me the real
name